a 12 year old boy has been remanded into
secure accommodation after he was
charged with murdering a six-year-old
woman who was hit by a car in Sheffield
on Wednesday the boy appeared at
Sheffield youth court this morning
Katarina vitotsi joins me now from
Sheffield what is the latest Katarina
well yes in a 30-minute hearing this
morning the 12 year old boy appeared as
you say at Sheffield Youth Court he
spoke earlier to confirm his name and
date of birth we can't identify him for
legal reasons due to his age but he is
accused of the murder of 60 year old
grandmother Marsha Grant police say she
died after being hit by a car outside a
residential property in Sheffield on
Wednesday evening the 12 year old boy
has now been remanded into secure
accommodation whilst legal proceedings
continue around him and he will be next
seen in court at Sheffield Crown court
on Tuesday next week and we we have
learned a little bit more about the
victim of this of this incident martial
Grant 60 years old a grandmother as I
say her family have posted a very moving
tribute to her where they describe her
as warm loving a dedicated wife mother
grandmother sister and friend and a
pillar of her community her loss has
already sent shock waves through all who
knew her or was lucky enough to be
included in her orbit we asked for
privacy at this very difficult time
whilst further investigations are
underway so just to reiterate that that
a 12 year old boy accused of her murder
and also another count of possession of
a bladed article appearing here at
Sheffield youth court today will next
appear at Shuffle Sheffield Crown court
on Tuesday next week remanded in the
secure accommodation until that time